douche froide pour les républicains dans
la première circonscription des yvelines
à droite depuis 1963 le bastion a cédé
sous la vague de la république en marche
françois-xavier bellamy n'a pas réussi à
inverser la tendance du premier tour où
il avait réalisé seulement 27 49 % des
suffrages contre 42 15 % pour le
candidat de la république en marche
didier baichère malgré une belle
remontée l'homme politique de 31 ans
s'inclinent finalement 2 827 voix
j'espérais au soir du premier tour et
j'en étais convaincu que nous pouvions
rattraper le retard pourtant important
qui nous séparer de notre concurrent
dans marx était possible et on l'a
prouvé
on a reçu 7000 voix de plus dans l'entré
deux tours mais on s'arrête voilà sur le
seuil de cette victoire parce que je
crois profondément c'est que nous vivons
un phénomène national sur lequel
finalement on avait bien peu de prise il
suffit de constater les autres scores
des yvelines et de voir que là on fait
le plein des meilleurs scores de toutes
les yvelines aujourd'hui et c'est
vraiment une fierté
la défaite de françois xavier bellamy
est également un coup dur pour le député
dvd sortant françois de mazières
mais le maire de versailles qui avait
remporté la circonscription en 2012 avec
56% des voix est prêt à travailler a
conseillé le nouveau député
je lui ai proposé tout alors concevoir
rapidement pour lui d'y aller aussi il
me semble important de suivre en temps
parlementaire
c'est évident il ya aucune raison à
partir du moment où les électeurs ont
décidé qu'ils étaient deux députés la
presse penseurs des idées qu'on ne
travaille pas avec lui qu'on travaille
quant à soi tout positive pour cette
belle soeur constance après l'annoncé
officielle dans sa permanence de
campagne place charreaux à versailles
didier béchard analyse avec ses soutiens
les scores dans les différentes communes
dans le détail le candidat l'emportent
de 27 points à montigny le bretonneux et
de 41 points lieu en cour à versailles
c'est françois-xavier bellamy qui
l'emportent ils totalisent plus de 60
29% des suffrages
je pensais pas honnêtement versailles
remontrer autant par rapport à la
semaine dernière mais d'un autre côté la
semaine dernière c'était vraiment une
surprise d'être au coude à coude sur
versailles donc je pense que j'avais
beaucoup de gens qui n'avaient pas voté
la semaine dernière donc très bien pour
mon concurrent d'avoir remonté pour lui
à versailles comme ça ça partage un peu
la peine avec lui après avoir savouré sa
victoire dans sa permanence didier
pêcheurs se remettra en marche dès ce
mercredi pour ses premiers pas à
l'assemblée nationale
[Musique]
les étudiants comme un spectre c'était
l'appel à la manifestation du 9 mars
place de la république à paris a été
entendue
un rassemblement sans réelle
organisation mais un seul objectif
aujourd'hui tous dans la rue unis face à
elle comme beaucoup il n'y a rien de bon
là dedans que celui qui trouve un seul
truc en faveur des travailleurs qu'il le
dise il n'y a rien pour les travailleurs
doute pour les risques pour les patrons
pour les entrepreneurs en a ras-le-bol
de ça la pétition c'est très bien mais
ça va à la déchiqueteuse
il va falloir des grèves des
mobilisations des manifestations parce
que ces gens là ils ne comprennent pas
les discussions dans les rangs des
syndicats et des partis de gauche qui
manifestent aujourd'hui contre la
politique d'un gouvernement socialiste
une manifestation dont les lycéens et
étudiants se sont emparés aujourd'hui
c'est important d'être dans la rue
puisque la loi travail c'est tout
simplement un recul de 70 ans en arrière
sur le droit des travailleurs et que
c'est la précarité pour les jeunes et
pour les étudiants aujourd'hui se
mobiliser c'est la seule solution pour
pour gagner pour gagner de nouveaux
droits pour les jeunes et pour empêcher
que ces touareg recist parce qu'ici
autres et non négociable est demandée
par la grande majorité de syndicats une
manifestation aujourd'hui qui sera un
véritable thermomètre social pour le
gouvernement
nous demandons qu'il y ait un travail de
discussion et des mesures qui soient
prises mais pas celle de ce texte donc
tous demandent ouvertement de comprendre
et d'entendre que ce texte n'est pas bon
il leur retirer on discute ce que nous
ne voulons pas c'est le statu quo mais
gouvernement de gauche qui fait une
politique de droite
moi je fais pas la différence est que
sarkozy nous on est pas de cette
majorité on l'a jamais été au niveau du
parti gauche et de jean luc mélenchon
donc c'est pas aujourd'hui que ça va
changer au contraire donc on serait ravi
de faire tomber ce gouvernement
mouvement qui a commencé timidement à 14
heures mais qui a vu ses rangs grossir
jusqu'à recouvrir l'ensemble de la place
de la république avant un départ vers la
place de la nation
en france ce sont environ 150
manifestations qui est prévue
aujourd'hui
[Musique]